everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk this is pod
sessions number three if you're just
joining I've always wanted to bring
interesting people together and talk
about current events I think that that
dude from swingers five I always get
this last name of Aubry up baavraa
baavraa baavraa had like that dinner
party of like dinner thing that like
caught my attention on cable like 17
years ago when I used to consume content
as my three guests will say in a minute
they consumed an obnoxious amount of
content will speak to that issue in a
minute but uh finally we're doing it
obviously I referenced before my career
changed when I started doing these jam
sessions at South by Southwest and other
places with people that went on to you
know become the biggest investors and
makers of the greatest apps and I think
we're living through a culture shift
right now around you know it's why I
wrote crushing it I just think there's
more room way more room for us to do our
thing in this internet thing than we
realize and even I didn't realize how
much and that's all I focused on for a
decade so I realized wow there's a lot
more to go I've quadrupled down over the
last 24 months it's changed a lot for me
and and I try to bring on people who I
think are interesting entrepreneurs
doing fun stuff and also have a point of
view on on that world and so that's what
we're doing here and so I'm super
excited for these three one I know
pretty darn well the other two I'm
getting to know and actually had
meetings with as recently as this
morning for the first time even though
Jerry's played a bunch of basketball
with my crew and we'll get into that and
and I'm excited about this show I think
it's me a good one so why don't we do
the introduction part origins I would
like you to introduce yourself what you
do and maybe like a quick one-minute
recap four to six bullets on yourself
why don't you go alright so I think
going first is worse let's talk about
that first
before we go to entrust your mother say
it's always the worst because they have
time to think about what they're gonna
say I promise I won't think alright know
what I'm saying little think I know Liz
well enough to know that um but you know
everybody at this table we're more like
five years
and carry my people I don't everyone
that I mister do you know everybody you
tell everybody heretofore from ego no
I'm just gonna say I tell everyone that
I'm gonna say I'm not something female
version of you I'm really the amount of
people that tell me there's a female
Gary Vee is absurd but I think I'm gonna
go with that I respect it and my dad
isn't scary so it works anyways other
than my dad's name being Gary my name is
Danielle Schneider I have a label called
Danny Joe with my sister Jody who's
Skeeter by the way for more support and
dance are all real questions we share a
brand she's here she's here as my
lifeline in case you guys want to talk
but I share a brain what percentage is
you and what percentage like 87 more
like it was anyone's gonna be 80 it's
made by no I'm kidding she's the better
man she doesn't the microf and so we've
we've had a label we're going on our
10th year anniversary
wow that's pretty phenomenal right to
make a limited edition piece of jewelry
with a 10 on it and just give it to me
so I can flip it on eBay and for
collaboration during the show with Gary
Vaynerchuk sit on all those channels got
it so we've had and he'll keep how much
percentage of the action he's going
nonprofit events let's keep it going up
so we've had a label for 10 years the
lifestyle brand it's built on our
sisterhood our community we're known for
our statement jewelry and having made
our collection the large majority of it
here in New York City and within the
last year we've expanded into fitness
health and wellness travel and
storytelling by executing it yourself or
by licensing the brand to people making
products in those worlds executing it to
ourselves with the intention of a
possibly understood
so we most recently launched a fitness
movement called box arena that's a
hybrid of boxing in ballet and we're
using that as a tool to build the
community and sweat with the people that
we love and travel to our favorite
places with them under the Danny Joe
travels retreat series so a lot to talk
about but I want you guys to fill me in
so I can think about what I
no go ahead my name is Liz s-line I have
worked in the influencer space for
probably six years now you started when
you were three I started when I was
three I was actually in college I went
to NYU and I had read an article that
Instagram had just raised a series a of
seven million dollars and they had a
million users but back story I had
gotten really sick with chronic Lyme
disease my junior year so I had always
thought I was gonna go work in
publishing and advertising with a
background you know I had an internship
at Connie and asked you and I was barely
getting through school and so yeah I was
because of the disease not like me
reason no totally by the way Tyler when
is my report card getting I can't get to
data you because I already got it once
like flashed it posted an Instagram
photo but then lost it
which probably speaks to why there were
so many D's in that side but this time
I'm gonna get it I'm gonna frame it
somewhere massive probably right there
I'm gonna move macho-man down and I'm
gonna put it right there so as soon as
you walk in it sets the tone of what
you're dealing with I'm sorry keep going
cool yeah and so I was just in bed one
day and read the article um tried to
make a few names they were taken and I
was like well I live in New York so here
we are in New York City was available
and it registered and I kind of forgot
about it I mean and I didn't tell anyone
because sure when you sign up for
MySpace or something you're not I'm not
hey Danny I signed it from my different
check it out yeah um and then that took
off rather slowly the photos on there
were atrocious they're still there you
can take a look I won't because you took
them yeah I mean they're smart O's but
not creative I would say a hybrid of the
two they're people that are far more
creative than I am um but you know both
my parents are entrepreneurs and I have
loved watching them start their own
businesses and I always wanted to do
that so then I graduated and started to
see a shift and why wouldn't a brand pay
you know 40 grand
or someone with a hundred thousand
followers as opposed to 40 grand for a
print page or print magazine I had a
hundred thousand in circulation so um
yeah I met two of I mean should I go
into it briefly yeah so um yeah I met my
first two co-founders and we started
what was really the first influencer
Instagram marketing agency at that time
Nike was our first client they paid us
$50 in cash and I remember telling my
mom like mom and she was like oh Jesus
um yeah and I was there for two years
and then left to start an agency called
cycle which was part of a larger
full-service agency called laundry
service and we represented a roster of
talent and really I think provided a
backbone to their careers that we're
launching in this space and then we were
acquired so long story short on how the
show that was a question again do you
want to answer it so you still own at
New York City yep but I want to do want
to sell my DJ yes you need to calm it
down but yeah I wanted to follow your
people she's our people you've never met
Jerry before his wife is gorgeous waiter
everything about his life we did we base
it in a podcast out there well it'll be
here at six o'clock did you guys film it
I see
why we need you because we put out our
podcast at 5:59 p.m. all right chair and
by the way going last is not all it's
cracked up to be cuz now I gotta follow
those two stories like the chubby
Italian movie about the chubby kid from
Bensonhurst Brooklyn spine but no
phenomena like you're on the right side
of this conversation it's worse when
it's the reverse I know right you've got
it you figured it out I've been there
too uh I guess I am Jerry Ferrara I am
an actor which growing up in Bensonhurst
Brooklyn was not the easiest trade I
would say there's not a lot of other
actors where I was growing up so I was
kind of a little bit of the but you were
right from the get I mean from teenage
years about 15 16 years old I just it
was really of a love of movies and
television that I just wanted to find
the way in I I could have easily have
been you know a camera operator or an
editor I just wanted to be in that world
arted with acting because I was to make
it a I was failing out of a community
college yes yes doing it right acting
class because I was totally I was told
the professor will give us an E and a if
you just show up so I took this anything
class like alright I'm gonna finally put
my mom swimming yeah yeah I'm gonna
prove to my mom I could get an A and uh
I went into this acting class and it was
totally terrifying and I just went I
remember walking out there being like I
don't know if this is what I'm supposed
to do but I think this is what I want to
do and I just felt weird and right it's
just yeah I just wanted to do it again
and I never stopped from that moment on
I started doing extra work I was an
extra in Oz on HP I was an extra in the
pilot of Sex in the City
what yes shot a club scene at limelight
in 1998 I was in that doing in the
background could barely see me I've
never revealed where you what what frame
it is fans these fans please find this
and tweet nough with the screen shot
he's funny and I looked way different
but uh I'll wrap it up quickly
all right around there I knew I needed
to venture out west cuz that at the time
was where the business was that's where
the action was moved out to LA and about
four or five years
what I got cast an entourage which
worked out it worked out eight seasons
and then uh bounced around in movies
after that for a little while trying to
reinvent cuz you know you become that
character and how many some point I mean
let's talk about four four seconds I
mean you do look different enough that
maybe of a prayer they're not being as
bad as it could be right but it must
happen a lot that people reference you
as turtle it certainly did in the moment
and say season three of the show that's
the only way you ever get just in life
it was it yeah I do poke holes in the
whole typecasting theory because you
know where I was going now I've been
working on in the show power for five
years yep I'm kind of typecast again now
it's outside like I just met a few
people here like Proctor oh my gosh my
girl yeah so it's like it almost
disproves the theory if tiny has an
equal to me guys fire those
someone else firing him right in his
[ __ ] face right now
I just don't god you really this is what
we do on the pod sessions episode three
yes say he said no power more than three
no cry dude this is not you reference
him as his new character Oh George we
talked about power right you know what
is OG character okay get out of here I
didn't mean where I was going with that
was in a way a kind of disproves
typecasting as a whole because if I was
it only was Turtles exactly right
how do I get typecast again that there's
people don't know anything about
entourage you only know me from path so
your goal is to be typecast seven times
as many times as possible all that means
as I work the looks exactly right so uh
and Here I am back in New York still
working so binding and eSports you're
doing about just like some cool new
sports stuff she got married recently
just got married aside to stay with this
for the rest of their life that is that
did happen shockingly enough so uh so
life is good life is good this is my
favorite part of the show I go right to
it
[Music]
why'd you dodged my question we you know
that we know that answer I'm trying to
teach the kids that you can actually
make money and influence um alright this
I want to know what you're currently
obsessed with what is happening in
culture or in your life that you were
obsessed with now the last show all
three people went around and made
[ __ ] like Martin Luther King Gandhi
manifestos it was literally like peace
and like health and like world love I
mean like you bought some weird pillow
at Bed Bath & Beyond cuz you owes you
like slobber at night and this pillow
absorbs it and now you're obsessed with
this pillow like or like you follow this
new weird Instagram account back to your
rule is in my world like that has six
hundred followers but
believe it's gonna have four million or
Jerry like you and I had this meeting
earlier and I said the hip-hop artists I
guess maybe you know you know like what
are you currently obsessed with Jerry go
first we're gonna other way around
I'm wait I was like spend you know what
I'm ready for it god I promise this is
not like a plug but I am I am obsessed
with he's been plugging all with gaming
and gaming and eSports and I'm currently
Scout a scout and a consultant for the
Knicks on their gaming squad and that
requires me being on Twitch day and a
night scouting these players it's like
the closest I could come to being a part
of a real sports franchise looking at
I'm scouting and you're scouting yes I
think Ricky in Minnesota should we
should sign him he's a good player well
draft him that's what the cool thing is
about the 2k league is these I call them
kids but they're always for the 2k
leaked this is for that's NBA 2k league
they like we look good are you at 2k I'm
pretty good but I can't I can't touch
some of these guys who have been playing
professionally there what are you at
bubble hockey you I could be taken in
bubble hockey okay we'll do that
all right I can be taken in bubble
hockey though only cuz it's been a lot
less Daniel you don't know Danny you
don't know what you've never seen a
hockey game Tony do you oh thank god
okay Bobo hockey's the machine that's in
a bubble and you see it at the arcade
and people play hockey Russia 87% of the
game comes through all right Jenna Han
he's obsessed with twitch eSports and
scouting yes for 2k yes who's the best
player you've seen or have you not been
able to drive no we haven't
so what will happen similar to the real
NBA is they will announce a lottery
order yeah then we will all sit in the
war room
yeah and draft these guys and they will
move to the city that and and hey when
somebody's great okay yeah is there an
advantage for them to use like the
Warriors or the Cavs see here's the
thing they use their own created player
that's my same as change I so it's no
longer like all I'm gonna play you it
but there's your question though yes if
you do it that way the Warriors are
obvious sure of course major advantage
but these guys are creating their own
player and swatting up and they're
playing five verse five and you yes and
do they have to be themselves or can
they create a seven-foot 9 porzingis
they could absolutely do that
but then they become vulnerable and
you know I don't want to miss the whole
like Gandhi thing but I'm really
interested in learning more about the
psychology of marketing okay keep going
and I just think we're so inundated with
brands on a daily basis or consumption
just all the information in range of
media information what have you and so
learning how brands can kind of break
through it not even brands but people
and any butters anyone do you think that
your intuitive I think so to like just
like in our one meeting and now like
just kind of some things I think that's
a good space for you to go I think
that's my space yeah I know nothing
about a fascinating though okay no nice
no more siblings on this kind of show no
but I think it's a good space for you
because thinking about like you know a
lot of people read that Instagram raised
money that didn't take them to the place
of like hey I can make the parallel of
once there's attention here
that translates to print I think that's
the only thing I had like using a sports
reference like I think I'm Mariano
Rivera all I think I have is intuitive
understanding of people's behaviors and
then I play that PlayBook over and over
whether then I learn the context of
twitch I'm gonna have a huge twitch
channel in 14 months because once I put
in the time to understand the context
it's game over
totally that's gonna be dope like
champions all right so that is where
you're thinking about so are you yeah
obviously I know like we got to talk off
some of the audience you have this
incredible situation where you're smart
and hard work put you in this incredible
spot is it a young entrepreneurs right
absolutely but like you're now in a
place where you can be thoughtful about
your next step or two or three
and so that's where you're kind of
putting your energy and trying to
understand where that translate have you
started thinking about voice like a LexA
and all that or not yet um I have I just
need to understand it a bit more I'm
really obsessed yeah I'm like I just
know it's all about friction like here's
what I think all three of you and
everybody listening put in a LexA or a
Google home in your bathroom and learn
that you can have it I just got it for
Christmas and I had it returned
yeah you don't like it it's nothing I
like it I just I carry boiz what why did
you money $30 so no I just I was like
I'm never gonna use this I don't I don't
I don't know under sound like right now
I can idiot yes yes I agree this clip
we're filming it right now in six years
we're gonna show this exact talk and
it's gonna be great because you're gonna
be starring in Apple's own pods
commercial
weird like this [ __ ] guy hi I'm Jerry
Brian you know what you need in your
home home pod because it's the bet no
here's why when people first got the
iPhone they didn't understand the power
that was gonna you don't realize the
apps that are gonna be built on top of
these products that are gonna completely
change your life and more importantly
the reason I like the bathroom move is I
do think a lot of people think about
their day early on and a lot runs
through your mind in the bathroom and so
like hey what's my calendar today like
you know hey remind me to buy this like
I like I think about seven hundred by
thinking about my upcoming day without
even looking at my calendar in the
shower I think about people I need to
connect with things that I need to get
that like the amount of things that run
through people's minds I'm like and if
you're elected you have Thunder Stan how
the Alexa works Alexa make sure I see
d-roc later
you know like stuff like that is intense
right Alexa yeah Lex are you alright
I'll tell you what happened I feel she
said something me right there she did
Jerry this is what's happening Alexa
absolutely reasoning and referenced your
acting career in her answer just now I
don't know
but boy facts I'm joking I'm joking what
nobody's coming I want to know what
you're obsessed with see but Shawn Oh
Lex this is the current short-term
problem with Alexa and if you don't get
used to talking to her by the time she's
got it all figured out you were all
gonna be behind but even voice voice
authentication it will be more powerful
than image recognition guys voice is the
[ __ ] jam right can we leave with
Alexis do we get little to go oh we
might have some homeless out on the
street Alexis Jerry sold us for six
bucks
all right currently obsessed with oh
also I'm obsessed with those Instagram
accounts for their like icing cakes and
like cut have you ever seen those
accounts they're mesmerizing which is
your favorite do you know I don't like
image space I like weird so none of them
did a good job branding enough to make
you remember yeah and like they cut
things and like there's it's just blah
you're talking so you're talking about
something different time I'm obsessed
with a few things one the short answer
Shazam and it kind of ties into the like
voice and like that digital like you
love Shazam I I love shoes it because
you want to know what song that is any
time I walk into a restaurant bathroom
or a dinner or a gas station or the last
time I walked into a gas station now
let's focus on this part can we tell us
that story real quick please
but anyways I'm obsessed with Shazam
it's how I've discovered some of my
favorite songs the entire world what is
your favorite song you ever do so right
now I've Shazam I'm obsessed with Luda
I'm gonna say I'm gonna botch his name
Ludovico Einaudi okay
assess memories yes I got it
ah yeah we're all there and and we're
just waiting for the next part is the
song called alight yeah Lu hya okay uh I
forget who it is
I actually Instagram to rather than the
other day in my insta story and they
only have 3000 Instagram pause I think
they're gonna be massive I'm also
obsessed with what's your handle I want
to I want to put this down because I
think you're gonna win this game and we
will also clip this recall it for you
send it to you you can post it and
you'll be amazing and Jerry will be an
hypocrite and and there's a song called
Porto anyways I'm gonna send you guys a
playlist just for this why don't you
start a Spotify playlist right now
around the brand which i think is a huge
marketing strategy my Monday to Monday
playlist right is killing it for me like
almost funny you feature 40,000 Gary
Gary why are you feature it why don't
you feature your song on it yeah cuz you
have a way bigger reach them no no but
look we're gonna use this audience okay
and now you're gonna star one I would
like a playlist
I'm gonna make you sending a playlist
can you make a commitment you're both in
here right yeah you guys make the
decisions yeah you're looking at can you
guys confirm that by tonight yeah your
brand will have a Spotify playlist
she's coming to you and you're welcome
to come you know this you know this part
about my life I get invited to so much
also [ __ ] Tyler deletes it Gary come on
I ever go to anything besides damn I'm
gonna do the playlist by tomorrow
vintage all things vintage and getting
back to our roots and old world and
storytelling our roots of the 1990s the
30s yeah
simpler and women were wearing corsets
or here's our rocking corsets yeah
actually
but I mean for real like like a real not
in like a pseudo interpreted 2018 world
I mean some straight 1920s gangster [ __ ]
I really
but what I'm I know that you reinter
know what I'm really excited about is
the usage of vintage and things of the
past as a means to story tell I don't
rate with in fashion I'm sick of
everything I'm sick of Instagram annual
look your biggest problem is your
absurdly cool Fant Lauder
yeah your biggest issue is that your
outrageously cool thank you like
actually actually on a very like
complimentary kick you might be the
coolest person I know
Jerry can you make me walk out now I
know 48 minutes ago but I like Alexa
who's the coolest person I was that was
me she's very smart
Mia like I think it was know that was
Annie Joe thank you so much sweetheart I
love you too are you gonna become best
friends with Alexa yeah if you think
she's that great I think you should
start an Instagram account called you
like your name and Alexa Danielle and
Alexa yes and like you should post three
times a day of you and your adventures
with Alexa no no no no you've gotta
learn how to do this yourself I know
playbook all right I actually think one
of the biggest Instagram counts sitting
and waiting is somebody's person's name
and Alexa like kind of these joint
accounts there's something incredibly
creative well that's why I'm putting out
there and and here's work oftentimes
Alexa shut up that's just so I say it
because in a lot of my talks I always
say that 99 percent the reason I gave
away all my best advice is because 99
percent of you are not gonna take it
like the reason I just did this last
little skit was in a week I'm gonna go
look how many people did it right in
reality is one percent of this listening
audience Taylor's making Danielle and
Alexa right now that's what
doing thank you it was time I work for
you I've always had this secretly weird
concern you're a double agent feel like
I've been going on or a family buy like
all your people ever since the first day
I came here Jerry you hired me outside
what uh let's talk about the Super Ball
it just happened
tell me about your Super Bowl experience
plan okay so let's have time show the
Justin Timberlake yeah okay so let's
talk about let's talk about this the
Super Bowl you're on the plane the whole
time
a majority of it where were you before
you landed I was in Los Angeles and you
came to New York and I came to San
Francisco Oh interesting now that was a
five-second flight so tell me about this
who else was on the plane and was it
weird because you knew the whole country
was doing one thing and you and these
200 weird people yeah I also couldn't
watch it on YouTube TV on my phone so
was the was the you know how the pilots
which big sporting meant to do this
stuff were they like update Eagles Simon
we're doing that and with half the plane
be like yeah and the other half be like
what were you listening to John is the
best I don't if you know this Daniel
would you grab crushing it please and
thank you and can you go to the back
yeah and can you read what John Mayer
said about John Mayer quote Geary is
helping to calibrate the desires and
expectations of a new generation
searching for a way to break through the
noise he's loud he's high-energy and
he's exactly right that's so well and I
always like your voice should I do the
rock I should do whatever which one
really now is cool I hope you're
listening the rock quotes a rock now I
do you say it let the rock would say it
no can you maybe wait hang on I'm
passing it off to jail
laughing I don't have a rocket
presentation of crushing it the best
book ever in let's move on Danny what
was your what was your Super Bowl
experience so I watched the Super Bowl I
changed my parents flight I don't know
if there's a lot of things about me that
a lot of people know because I'm an open
book I'm Jewish the thing that everybody
knows is I'm obsessed with my family and
I would do anything I need them near me
all the time that's right so my parents
were here and they were meant to fly
over here for my niece's third birthday
they were meant to fly home during the
Superbowl to Jackson oh and you know
Gary what's your problem
so Gary this is my dad ghetto really
beat up about it but you're bigger Gator
fans bigger Jaguar fair Wow however
matters you guys are so paying wack
you're looking at him from job David
Gerard
I mean Jody Jody should really well I
don't really give a [ __ ] to be
conclusion you don't know even though -
do you even know who Maurice jones-drew
is yeah Joel Maggie you remember like
ten years ago
okay go ahead anyways I've had this Gary
so he's supposed to get on flavors right
should what we became friends weird some
Winchell a promised dinner and we really
got well actually we met during the name
myself I said nasty air blood yeah but
the dinner at pencils of promise was
really and when we realized we just the
Gary thing was huge seven guests are
leaving there's a jerk there's none
there's really general ready ready name
Gary's that you know we play the game
game okay not even know of you know Gary
Vaynerchuk Gary Owen great good comedian
yeah what do you mind
yep I'd met Gary Shandling once okay is
that a real person
he's real good I know I think you have a
point Larry Schneider and Gary
Vaynerchuk that because it's hard it's
crazy hard breath we bonded I was my dad
you know this this was the best like 18
months ago there was an article that
came out that said the name Gary is
about to go instinct like no that's it
it's over people are stuck
well I know that I'm single-handedly I
actually met somebody in Minnesota at a
high at an IHOP that almost named their
kid Vayner no yeah actually it was like
and the wife was like I'm like holding
the little guy and was like honestly our
third one locked in anyway nonetheless
Gary's about to become extinct we can't
let that - know that there's a Facebook
ad that you can run excuse me a Twitter
ad that you can run based on first names
so I run ads on Twitter
hey Gary its Gary I'm sorry probably
heard by now we're finished for this and
either with you let's rally like a
mother find it was great like all these
can we pull that up we could probably
find I don't know if it was a should be
like a Jerry can if it's like a Gary
virtual convention so anyway that's it
look like literally you named one dead
Gary heads one living Gary besides me I
changed my mom and dad's play yes they
stayed I had to leave the next morning
yes their flight was at 8:00 a.m. you
know my dad went to wake up at 3:45 we
got a huge fight about I said this is
ridiculous he says I'm anxious what do
you want from me you know I stayed here
for the Superbowl I'm like I had a
stupid handsome by the way he's adorable
and how was he 72 73
he looks seven he says what do you want
from me he says saying with your entire
family for the Superbowl is not a
punishment like who watched the game
my dad Greg Jodi me my mom Margo at baby
leaf babies are no random invite this is
a very tight-knit community remember
what do you want from me that's what he
knows someone's like exasperate what do
you want from me by the way watch about
my insta story on Daniele Schneider I'm
rooting for I was rooting for the Eagles
I'm so sick yeah it's not a big football
whatever them is Tom Brady good-looking
goals Eagles yeah but I'm sick of
looking at him I like a little bit of
character I agree it looks like an
Android he's good-looking she's out
walking my bleep you think he's
good-looking this I mean I just don't
even like it
I just like a little rough in his outfit
walking into the game no I don't look at
anything anything differently about a
graciously you know what the single
reason I love you is that scene the
single reason all the Tom Brady sweetie
except that he was a good that kind of
made me scared when I was like [ __ ] one
day he's gonna retire I'm gonna rule the
world which means I'm gonna have to
stumble on him somewhere in like 50s and
then he's gonna be this great see
Jordans easy
I hate Jordan and it's easy he's a bad
[ __ ] dude yes just so everybody knows
listen you can be mad at me no not my
best guy on earth breathing on the other
hand that I've got way further than that
Danny okay you don't understand who I am
I've paid people to find [ __ ] okay this
is what you got on me it's not you I'd
give a [ __ ] I mean Brady who I need to
tear down think I'm important no no no
you're very important I just blindly
believed in you're right you're the
coolest person I know by the way if your
Instagram doesn't have that quote it's
gonna make your URL link email ads for
Danielle people on sweaters fans of Gary
it works every time that are here that
wasn't the best but then you like broke
my heart at the end when you switched
over and said [ __ ] he's a good doing a
two minute story about that scene unbeli
and listen I I not that Tom Brady needs
to get put up on any further in the show
there's a charity golf tournament and we
get paired up and the Vince character in
the giant drama character get paired up
with Tom Brady and he's like the nicest
guy in the world I hate him cuz I'm a
Giants fan and he wins me over he's know
anything about sports and I fall I get a
man crush on Brady in the end of the
episode but that was initially supposed
to be the Vince and Johnny Drama
character versus the Manning brothers
and about a week and a half before
something happened they pulled out of
the episode the whole episode was
written for them and we still had to
shoot the episode so I think it was
Wahlberg who suggested like listen I and
this was off the Brady knee surgery
season so he was just getting ready to
come back he's like I think I could get
Brady to do it'll be me and Brady
the episode replacing the Manning
brothers so he steps in fills those
shoes and kills us now we're rewriting
the episode and doug ellin the show
creator is like what would your
character say the brady like a giant fan
who hates Brady I said let's really get
the heart of New York I call my buddy
Paul I grew up with Brooklyn as it gets
I'm like a Paul he's not speaker like if
you saw and this is like if you saw Tom
Brady in the street a week before the
Super Bowl what would you say to him
he's like I [ __ ] say Tom Brady
[ __ ] sucks [ __ ] balls done thank
you hung up the phone went right into
the episode and that you want talking
about things that get quoted to me that
is one of the quotes that gets that gets
hit on me all the but you love him what
you were gonna say listen he bailed us
out of a jam for sure cuz we would have
had a problem I like Hitler more than
Tom yeah that's where I what just want
everybody understand that's my truth I
hate Tom Brady i Gary Vaynerchuk hate
you understand there's real life and
then there's the Jets to me it's very
simple everything in real life and
everything in real life 99% of my life
is very good I'm a good guy I do the
right thing I don't say ludicrous things
like I just said a good guy in Jets life
let me give you a good one in Jets life
cuz you have a letter day this is great
in real and Jets life let me give you a
great story I don't know seven years ago
at the Meadowlands just walking 11 year
old boy maybe nine walking by with a
Brady Jersey I checked him this is
literally child abuse I check a kid I
check him I bump into him he goes into
the fence he goes into that's his dad
looks at me like writing I go what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do about it
guys you don't understand I get it I get
it I get it
yeah the pitch oh yeah ready Pittsburgh
game Jets are playing Pittsburgh the
Jets miraculously in this season when
four or five games miraculously beat a
good Pittsburgh team at home so
Pittsburgh for anybody knows the NFL
they travel half the stadium Steeler
fans I don't like when people come to my
house and disrespect me this 87 year old
man is mucking up the stairs now stick
with me now stick with me he's 87 Tyler
was 87 guys he he's walking up the
stairs slowly right the Jets have
clearly won it's late fourth quarter 23
6 I stand up and I go hey old man now
you're finished right everybody hears me
hey old man you're [ __ ] finished
referring to the Steelers are him and
then I go and I don't mean the game so
so look I feel like I'm you're an
abusive jet I'm a very bad person
I do want on the Jets I do let's move on
before I lose all my fans your Super
Bowl experience yeah uh we hosted some
friends and you know me my wife host
some friends and I think I consumed
about 4,500 calories like what oh there
oh there was like a chili situation and
a homemade guacamole and a buffalo
cauliflower and then we went we got ice
cream from this place and that's where
it all went terribly wrong what place do
you want fellows and Williams we're a
great place and they got a flavor called
Santa's cookies let me tell you
interesting food and I made a promise to
myself on my okay I'm gonna have all
this and then when everyone leaves I
even said to my wife I'm like we're
throwing this freaking ice cream away
and then when I was getting ready to do
it I'm like we should give it one more
day one more day yesterday you ate it
yesterday it bled into the Monday why
are you bringing and it's still there by
the way guys it's they're still like so
we go over and here's how sick I am I
walk around this day at three times
since I've been in your offices I've
thought about oh I got that [ __ ] ice
cream
three separate times since I've been in
your office I've thought about that
you're hired you're hired
so that's really what I made that being
that I wasn't that interested in the
game and I love football but the game
didn't interest me I made it about the
food D what is your favorite current app
on your phone like new new fit new
favorite app or do you not have one
because this is actually an interesting
debate for me and I'll let you guys use
that because one of things that's
interesting to me is how difficult it is
actually how about this when's the last
time you download it a new app for your
phone D probably something related to
filters that's fine but like when maybe
a month ago okay listen I downloaded
this before app yesterday respect I
don't want to say you please do cuz like
I make fun of because I don't think I
tell you champion fun of it because I I
find that I downloaded venmo cuz I
didn't really understand what it let me
tell you somehow I don't where I was for
the crystal investors in Bembo in 2009
and it's the best investment I ever made
I'm like this is app yeah but guess what
yes I am it's the best investment I made
and the worst it was the best cuz I
there's not much I've been more right
about it was the worst because they sold
so early the economics to being Ryan a
weren't even remotely close I've been so
much I made way more money I'm being
wronged and that is probably one of the
most right things so you're right though
I will make I mean you just [ __ ] died
because I won my fantasy league by the
way but if I do dominate who did you
crush name one of your buddies R and be
like eat [ __ ] Rick ah Taylor is Hillary
Taylor I got you sorry it happened and
he had top girl you put up like 48
points and I still managed Jake last
time you've downloaded app Jesus Christ
three weeks ago was it
water minder
interesting I need has it been working
no you need to know neither you never
that was it
visco what do you think it was okay
do you rock what's that map my run yeah
you want you want to know why I don't
download more apps two reasons in case
you were wondering one I'm out of a
capacity I mean I found one iPhone DF
Jenny what am i eight yeah it's good
I take better photos and all my ten
friends but the problem is in addition
to me being at capacity and it slows
your thing down
I'm just so overwhelming have another
thing to look at it you're only using
seven home exactly I should wipe out the
whole dog you're right alright what do
you want what do you want to Yap about
Liz open for him what's interesting what
do you want I am what you could also
talk to the community and maybe ask them
a question you could ask us a question
if you want you can take this anywhere
open for him as if we were not even in
the room nope I'm not going to so we're
gonna all look at you awkwardly Liz
until um I don't know I think it's just
the evolution of ourselves and how we
portray ourselves digitally so like what
are you thinking is next for you what do
you thinking is next and do you mean
from the perspective of like what
frontiers do you want to attack or are
you talking about are we living the PR
versions of ourselves yeah I mean like
like one of the reasons I think Danny is
so cool is if you see him do you feel
like you're living a totally different
life online or do you think that's your
life I think two things I think would
there I think what we're living in an
age where we have to be two versions the
real version and the digital version can
I ask you a question and all of you
because I think this is far more
interesting in this conversation because
I think we've all know this isn't a
zeitgeist I actually think that just
what always happened I think we always
lived a life outside public and price
right and for a lot of us you come from
a family that you know like you know
especially my immigrant family like
nothing left the house like everything
that happened those four walls nothing
like we would [ __ ] be no teeth and
then everybody walk and be like we're
fine no dirty laundry ever ever ever
and so like like using like 40 year old
moms like cool so now you're doing at an
Instagram but that used to be meeting up
40 and never talking about the real [ __ ]
so I think like we're stopped everybody
wants to fear monger technology like Oh
social media made us do this no no this
just scales what we've always done no we
were I think it's it's um I think what
you're saying is 100% accurate thank you
we're just more aware we're more aware
of it cuz we can physically scale yeah
but I mean what about Jen Z they don't I
don't think they realize it I think
they're living their true life digitally
because they're not they're less worried
about circumstance because I think
they're less at college than we aware of
all of this they think we're order and
realize none of it actually matters
maybe because I remember being an early
social media numbers like kids yeah and
put up your beer pong pictures cuz
college won't let you in like [ __ ]
cop like the USC didn't know Jer I'm
just um you you you got me hooked on
like so you're talking about your family
like so I think you can go one of two
ways then like you obviously embraced it
but also on a business perspective but
also seeing the way the world was going
but at what point did you make that
choice cuz you were raised like to not
let the private out and you've matured
and grown into uh just everything you
just said because something weird just
happened please for the love of God tell
me your socks are not Laker socks when
you're next Pistol Pete Maravich ladies
and gents a little bit better a little
bit oh come on you know I love Pistol
Pete that's what I don't like wearing
any other team but my team [ __ ] I won't
wear anything that's like of my
generation yeah okay you know like if
it's pre my generation
I loved where you were going literally
was like the best thing you said this a
podcast then I look down and I'm like if
he's wearing Kobe sucks who by the way I
love in a lot of high but I wouldn't
wear a Kobe Sox like I love Kobe but yes
let the record show I would not wear a
Kobe sir are you Colby best friends no
I've met them yes but no we're not best
friends I wish I bet sports friend you
have an answer
yeah I can't wait to hear that my bad
like like describe best righteously you
who's a professional athlete you have
the best relationship if you're like hey
come over for dinner they like cool like
that that is my phone
you can wallet while Danny goes yeah
that's like go ahead mister I've got so
many sports Jerry cuz the Greek you make
sense that yes there's a lot I miss you
cope them for sure but that's like you
know she's a ballerina it's a little
different am I gonna be like bring over
all of it I'm not joking this is not a
like I'm gonna get razzed on like I
think a lot of things are sports that
people don't do ballerina I'm asking a
few ballerinas consider ballerina being
a ballerina sport a hundred school I
believe that should we put a call math
series like no I fully believe that that
wasn't a leading question anyway I
actually didn't know how it was addition
Andy Roddick is dope I like Andy is your
second closest sports rebel okay close
is not right he's a really good friend
of mine but he's crushing on that show
amazing
Andy is is a stand-up guy really like
whispering Liz I think you know him mr.
Nigel Sylvester yes he's [ __ ] awesome
am i seeing him did you
that's a good [ __ ] question baby
right it's like a nighttime
know what I mean is like I don't want to
be like yeah I mean this person they're
friends and I hear this podcast
Jai disclaimer I'm a friend with the
wife and I'm like and I Instagram has
changed my whole world because every
time an athlete you know you're Oliver I
mean like I get I'm a hardcore fantasy
baseball players like I'm in love with
Devon Travis he's been hurt his two
years at the Blue Jays but like when he
followed me I'm like [ __ ] yes and like
nobody outside of like a blue jay says
you're the most excited about know
probably the most of Rahu's than most I
was the rock we lost our [ __ ] when the
rock filed me on Instagram cuz we all
shut down and we're like alright what
does this meet that happened in a three
week period where the rock Kevin Hart
and Metro boomin all followed me and I
was like okay I was hitting a different
like I was waiting the attention I
penetrated by putting out the best
[ __ ] content contextual to Instagram
around you know well and the reason why
I said let me look at my phone's not cuz
like oh there's so many it's I don't
want to say like oh me and this person
they're cooling in the here in his
pockets they're like we're not that
friggin cool like part of smarter like
I'm thinking about the people draymond
Green these are people I have really
great relationships yeah I don't think
anybody of them would consider me one of
their five or six best friends I haven't
gotten to that place with everybody I
expected to call Brandon Marshall is
probably the closing west map ratings
are pretty cool Wes Matthews I met I met
Frank Kaminsky like a lot of MBA guys
cuz everyone they know how big of a fan
I am at the NBA so but the the is not an
athlete but he's a coach yet he's like
Shh I might be able to get in the show
up for me if I ever need coach Cal
Calipari really he coached me at a
fantasy camp one time he was my coach of
mine you really want can we just let me
tell you no close but how I like
describe him is like almost like if
Frank Sinatra was a coach that's not
cool yeah it just makes you feel like oh
my like he really does make you feel
special and that dude is unbelievable
open forum Cody I just think we're
living in a really interesting time and
I personally coming from the vantage
point of fashion I'm having at being our
tenth anniversary I'm having a hard time
grappling with the way that the world is
moving especially now that you know I
have a niece and nephew in my life and
I'm watching you know the interactions
and the way the digital is affecting
that I see me feel bad about that
everyone's on their phone I do because I
think you're nice enough you should
spend more time on technology not less I
really do
i I understand but I want to you know
I'm saying things here today I mean the
Hitler thing I'm gonna have to do it
real quick I didn't mean it to everyone
I mean like my great great grandparents
got killed like buried themselves so
please before I have to spend an hour
and a half on Twitter apologizing I hope
everybody understood the tongue-in-cheek
of that but I do hate Tom Brady at a
level that is ridiculously uncomfortable
why Denise release an fu thing like this
is what parents do of every generation
your parents parents made them not want
to watch Elvis right like Madonna was
scary for kids of my age like Miley
Cyrus twerking
a couple minutes ago 60 or seven years
ago is lame
on Instagram what world do you think
your niece and nephew are gonna work it
not that I'm worried that they're gonna
be privy to like whatever on Instagram
it's not it's not like some sort of
censorship what I'm worried about is the
way that social media has the psychology
of it how it's affected human
relationships and I said horrible you
sure and what we owe each other is
pitbull and what friendships talk about
for a minute sure a lot of people want
to blame a lot of kids troubles on right
side but I want to blame it on the fact
that parents are teaching kids in their
first 15 years that they want everything
and they're the best and teaching no
reality of confrontation when you give
eighth place trophies to a
seven-year-old they have no
understanding how to deal with anything
so I think one of the things we do all
the time is we blame other forces not
ourselves when you have a country that
goes through 70 years of prosperity
pretty consistently we get into third
generation dynamics where people worry
about what milk is in their Starbucks
and they think that's a bad thing like
we just have no context of real life and
so I think
we've done Liz no I I mean this is the
world you're interested in we want to
blame things like that what we all got
bullied we just lived it a lot of us who
are over 35 lived in a world where when
you came in second place you cried
because you lost and now you cut you
know I mean I think we have to really be
very thoughtful about the way we're
parenting your sister no matter what is
parenting in a fundamentally different
way than your mother did and a
fundamentally different way that her
mother did and we end like anything you
can over correct in one way or the other
the micro analyzation of everything like
my parents didn't know anything that was
going on in my life like and and you
take the generation above me they
literally knew nothing because they
threw them outside and they went
we need here's where my point is
Facebook didn't make you vote for
somebody wait you know bullying like
this goes down baby do you know what I
mean it's short didn't cuz you clicked
things that made those ads show up in
front of you we have to take way more
responsibility before we blame social
media and Technology and until we start
taking accountability which we have
fundamentally avoided for the last 50
years we will lose a lot of these micro
battles so cool you want to blame
technology or something else but maybe
if you taught your kid how to take a
[ __ ] L in the first 10 years of their
life maybe they know how to take an L
right what are your thoughts of
parenting in New York City I think that
there's a lot of insanity but I want to
teach my kids how to take an L and
besides that but do you think growing up
in LA or New York course you product of
your environment and if your parents do
you love me I'm cool I think we should
all move here from Jacksonville I take
back everything I said Brooklyn and he's
dope his name's Gary but I think you
know I think very different I think
parenting is an unbelievably important
job and I think that the gravitas of it
for this latest generation made them
overcorrect in a way that is creating
vulnerability I really believe that yeah
but I don't even think it's kids I think
it's us too we're insecure to a hundred
there's an eBay yeah good meanwhile me
and everybody I know that had my
circumstances or DNA are cruising along
because we got [ __ ] on all the time when
we were kids and we know exactly I'm
being seriously I love you say yeah I'll
be like getting D's and F's and not
being the best at sports and like
[ __ ] like I learned how to love to
lose early on we do not teach that
anymore there's this great fear like I
love when my kid like playing basketball
with my little guy and beating him and
him crying I'm like yeah [ __ ]
grow that's what I wanted to ask in the
open forum
I don't ever let my nephew win cuz
you're smart but it but I actually
thought of this recently like we play a
little pickup hoops as bass me as a
little bit and like I got his folklore
every now and then but like I really
don't know Mike I even said to my wife
I'm like chef I gotta let him win right
there was not in me to when I win I
gotta wrap up he's given looks like like
he's a killer because he didn't beat me
in basketball to you 17 years old and
when he did it [ __ ] tasted amazing
because when you [ __ ] let your kids
win on dumb [ __ ] they don't understand
that gratitude or the process and they
definitely don't know how to deal with
adversity and so when Sally pants 49
says you're ugly on Instagram they
[ __ ] fold like a cheap [ __ ] chair
[ __ ] that's the show see ya
you